plus de deux kilomètres de long 24
mètres de large
auteur du tablier 60 mètres au dessus
des flots nous sommes en janvier 1995 le
pont de normandie est achevée l'objectif
reliés aux fleurs au havre et
désenclaver l'estuaire de la seine une
prouesse technologique et
environnemental sans précédent dont le
projet remonte à 1986 à l'époque il ne
s'appelait pas encore le pont de
normandie mais d'honfleur s'est enfin
décidée pierre méhaignerie le ministre
de l'équipement et de l'aménagement du
territoire vient de donner son feu vert
pour la réalisation du conte d'ampleur
le pont devient alors une source de
développement majeur pour la région
cette construction engendrera mille
emplois directs sans compter les
retombées touristiques et promotionnels
qui l'accompagneront les travaux
débutent dès 1988 deux ans après le
lancement du projet la construction
s'avère colossal pour certains ouvriers
cet édifice est le projet du je pense
qu'on peut être fier dimension plus le
pont de normandie un défi technologique
pour l'époque
les pylônes utilisés sont les plus hauts
du monde l'édifice au comme la tour
montparnasse peut résister à des vents
de plus de 300 km/heure
chaque étape de la construction devient
une épreuve à part entière il aura fallu
aux hommes qui ont défié l'estuaire de
la seine
plus de trois heures de numéro
d'équilibriste pour arriver à hisser le
dernier vouloir de la travée centrale du
pont de normandie
un travail d'hercule et de précision qui
repose sur des audaces technologique
unique au monde
à son achèvement en 1995 le pont de
normandie devient le plus grand pont à
haubans du monde sa portée atteint les
856 m c'est une première mondiale
on dépasse de plus de 250 m la portée du
plan de shanghai est donc le pont de
normandie c'est vraiment un saut
technologique et à l'échelle
internationale aujourd'hui le pont de
normandie les plus le plus grand pont à
haubans du monde sur la première marche
du podium
le pont y avoue soultan selim en turquie
depuis 2016 il permet de traverser le
détroit du bosphore sa portée 1408 m
[Musique]